Most pornography is as accurate to human sexual
experience as blockbuster superhero films
are to reality.
Pornography is adult entertainment, it's sex
theater; but it's not going to inherently
hurt you.
Religious groups harangue the public about
the dangers of porn on the body and mind,
but the evidence doesn't pan out.
A new study in the journal Sexual Medicine
explored the watching of visual sexual stimuli,
or VSS and its connection to erectile dysfunction.
Common sense might say that men who watch
a lot of porn might have trouble getting it
up in the presence of a real person because
their expectations don't match reality, but
this research found precisely the opposite!
Instead of inhibiting arousal, men who watched
porn got MORE erections!
And that result was maintained with as much
as 25 HOURS of porn-watching a week; which
is more than three hours a day.
So wait, if porn watching hoists the mainmast,
for lads, what about for lassies?
Firstly, which will come as NO SURPRISE to
some of you, women DO watch porn.
Though Pew Research only found 8 percent of
women in 2013 reported viewing porn -- up
from only 2 percent in 2010 -- PornHub's insights
team says, 23 percent of their viewers were
female; and a Dutch study in the Journal of
Sexual Medicine reported a massive 45 percent!
And according to that study pornography doesn't
increase sexual aggression or sexually transmitted
diseases -- lines touted by many pornographic
pugilists.
When adjusted for age and personality, men
who watched porn didn't see a change in the
number of sexual partners, though women did,
but only by point-three percent.
As an added bonus; in a study of 400 heterosexual
pornographic videos, women and men were found
to be equally represented as initiators of
sex, and in positions of power.
Plus, PornHub's Insights point out that both
men and women search for similar terms when
on their website, though usually at different
rates, and women were 80 to 100 percent more
likely to search for "rough sex" and terms
related to female-centric oral sex.
While negatively-skewed surveys about the
QUOTE "discovery of partners' sexual behaviors"
are often connected to feelings of jealousy,
anxiety and betrayal; A 2013 study in the
Journal of Sex and Marital Therapy found partners
who were honest with each other about their
pornographic habits had lower levels of distress,
and higher levels of relationship satisfaction!
Perhaps if the partners hadn't hidden their
preferences, it wouldn't have been as shocking?According
to the JSMT study, mutual enjoyment of pornography
increased happiness for couples as well; and
dishonesty about habits increased distrust
and dissatisfaction.
In the end, while porn can have negative effects
personally and relationally; some studies
on pornography are done on those already seeking
treatment for sexual deviance or dysfunction,
and others are simply not representative of
the actual population…
On top of that, many studies focus on heterosexual
couples, or specifically men.
Obviously, we need more study of women, and
non-traditional couples, relationships and
so on.
It's crazy to think we humans don't really
know much about how we humans are getting
it on.
This is still a private behavior, and it's
very difficult to openly study.
But overall, visual sexual stimuli seem to
be a benefit to men and women who are open
and honest about their sexuality; how not
strange at all does that sound??
How do you feel about this?
Would you be upset if your partner was watching
porn without you?
What
about together?